بعد أن أُجبر الجيش الروسي على
التراجع حول كييف ، جاء المذبحة إلى
الضوء
بوشا بوروديانكا والعديد من ضواحي كييف الأخرى المليئة بالجثث.
الوحدة تتحدث إلى CNN ، إنها كذبة كبيرة
بالنسبة لي مثل 24 فبراير قادم
حسنًا ، اذهبوا إليكم الجميع يذهبون إلى
العالم انشق نيكيتا تشيبرين من
الجيش الروسي وهرب إلى أوروبا
حيث قابلناه في مكان سري
وأظهره لي  يقول كتيب عسكري يحمل طابعًا
موقعًا من قبل قائد
الكتيبة 64 من الكتيبة الآلية ، الكولونيل أزيربيك
أوموبيكوف المعروف في أوكرانيا باسم
جزار الجزار توبرين ، إنه تلقى هو ورفاقه طلقات نارية
لقتل
أوامر على الرغم من أن روسيا نفت
ارتكاب قواتها أي مخالفات في ما يتعلق بذلك.
كان لدينا أمر مباشر بقتل أولئك
الذين أفشوا عن مواقعنا إذا
كان لدى شخص ما هاتف سُمح لنا بإطلاق النار عليه.
تم نشره في بيلاروسيا
قبل فترة وجيزة من الغزو المزعوم
لتدريب الجنود لم يكن لديهم أي فكرة عن
أنهم سيتقدمون قريبًا إلى
أوكرانيا ويقول إنهم لم يكونوا مستعدين للحرب
كما اعتقد الجميع أنهم يمكن أن يكونوا مثل
رامبو أولئك الذين قالوا إنني سأطلق النار على
الأوكرانيين بسهولة  قطعة من الكعكة عندما
ذهبوا إلى خط المواجهة ثم
عادوا كانوا كما لو أننا لا
نريد أي أطفال حرب يقول إنه تعرض أيضًا
لقصف مدفعي أوكراني
وأظهر لنا هذا الفيديو بالقرب من بلدة
ليبيثا غرب كييف كما أخبرني
رفض القتال لأنه كان
معارضًا للحرب ولأن قادته
وصفوه بالجبان وأعادوا تكليفه
بمهام وضيعة في الصف الخلفي
يقول إنه لم يشهد عمليات القتل الجماعي التي
اتهمت بها الوحدة ولكنه
شهد الكثير من  الجرائم ضد
المدنيين الأوكرانيين ، بما في ذلك النهب
الذي لم يحاولوا إخفاءه ، لقد فعلوا
ذلك علانية جدًا ، نعم ،
كل شيء ماذا يرون ، لقد
أردت هذا المنطق ، أردت كل شيء يا
أمي  القليل من الحمولة والسيارات
أيضًا وحتى الاغتصاب
رأيت مغتصبين يركضون وهم
يطاردون لأنهم ارتكبوا
اغتصاب الرجال الذين اغتصبوا رأيتهم يركضون
ثم علمت أنهم مغتصبون
اغتصبوا أمًا وابنة
ولم يتم سجنهم مطلقًا.  تمامًا
مثل ذلك ، تواصلت شبكة CNN مع
وزارة الدفاع الروسية للتعليق ،
لكننا لم نتلق ردًا ، وقد نفت روسيا
باستمرار أن تكون قواتها
مسؤولة عن جرائم ضد
المدنيين الأوكرانيين ، وأصدر الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
مرسوماً يشيد
ببندقية الحراس المنفصلة رقم 64.  لواء
اقتباس من هيرالد حكمة وأفعال جريئة
فر نيكيتا شيبرن من روسيا بينما كان في
إجازة يشعر بالعاطفة عندما يتحدث
عن ابنته البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات التي تركها
وراءه
ويقول إنه يريد الشهادة ضد
قادته أمام محكمة
دولية لإلقاء الضوء على ما حدث  في
الحرب لم يرغب أبدًا في أن يكون جزءًا من
pleiken CNN Berlin